the movie is based on real events that
transpired in South Korea at the start
we are introduced to the protagonist
Zhang taihoon a renowned doctor there is
not a single day that he's free due to
his impeccable surgery skills but
despite his busy schedule Jung always
manages time for his family he has a
loving wife and an adorable
five-year-old son unfortunately one day
his whole life Turns Upside Down when
his son is at school swimming he
suddenly collapses the boy is
immediately transferred to the hospital
but his condition is very critical
surprisingly his lungs have become Rock
Solid due to which they were unable to
function anymore this takes Jung by
surprise as his son was completely
normal until the morning the weird thing
is that he wasn't able to see any
symptoms despite being an experienced
doctor however Jung's worries do not end
there that night when his wife returns
home to get some stuff she suddenly
collapses and drops to the floor by the
time help arrives she is already dead
this rocks Jung as within a span of 12
hours both his son and wife have
mysteriously collapsed hence to find
answers he decides to cut open his wife
and perform an autopsy during the
procedure a distraught Jung is seen
trembling but nonetheless he
successfully completes it and comes to a
conclusion to everyone's surprise both
of her lungs have also been damaged
meaning that she is also afflicted by
the same condition that left their son
in a coma the condition is known as
pulmonary fibrosis where the lungs
become excessively damaged and scarred
generally someone suffering from it will
display symptoms like extreme coughing
weakness and loss of appetite but in
Jung's family's case they collapsed all
of a sudden it gets weirder here his
wife conducted a routine Health checkup
about three months back and the results
came out normal Jung is left in utter
disbelief as it is nearly impossible to
contract pulmonary fibrosis and die
inside three months later a devastated
John conducts his wife's final
ceremonies and Pays His respects he is
joined by his sister-in-law Han Young
Jew who is an attorney by profession the
two don't talk much as they are busy
crying their hearts out the following
day despite everything that he has been
through Jung resumes his duties he is at
a meeting where one of the doctors
mentions that the strange pulmonary
fibrosis cases are not new in fact a
cluster of cases were documented five
years ago a renowned physician from
another city apparently wrote some
articles on the problem however they
never came to light hearing this a
curious Jung decides to visit the
physician and learn more about the
disease after a long drive he finally
reaches the place and meets the
physician after a brief introduction the
latter takes out a file report and shows
that he documented more than 100 cases
in the past he even published articles
on it but the government never really
paid any attention because of this he
gave up and left his research altogether
Jung asks if there are any similarities
in the patients and the physician
responds that most of them became sick
in the spring season this indicates that
whatever the cause is it originates in
the earlier season that is winter
looking for answers John gathers a list
of families that lost their loved ones
to pulmonary fibrosis he then sends each
one of them a personalized letter asking
for information about the symptoms of
the disease however even after a week
not one replies so left with no other
options he decides to visit them one
after the other at first he approaches a
man named ping who has lost his wife as
well as both children Jung notices that
he has become a drunkard so he doesn't
ask much then he heads to an old lady's
house whose daughter is barely surviving
with the help of an artificial
respirator the lady herself has
contracted pulmonary fibrosis and it
appears as if she won't live for Long
John asks her a lot of questions but
doesn't find any relevant clues that
night while he is at home he has visions
of his wife and son but even in the
Visions junk sees them coughing
profusely when he looks around he
notices steam coming out of a humidifier
with this Jung snaps out of his vision
and realizes that both the old lady and
Peng had humidifiers at their homes
since these devices are most used in the
winter he deduces that they are the
cause of the unusual death hence wasting
no time he heads to the Korean Center
for Disease Control AKA The kcdc Great
band and explains the situation to them
normally such rumors are thwarted away
and no action is taken but since Jung is
a renowned and well-respected Doctor the
kcdc executives decide to help him out
in the next scene an experiment is
conducted in Jung's house to check if
the humidifiers are the actual cause of
the deaths several rats are placed
inside a cage and the humidifier is left
open for 24 hours there are also several
cameras placed throughout the room to
ensure that no one intervenes in the
experiment after a day the results come
out Zhang and his sister-in-law young
Zhu are summoned by a kcdc employee who
reveals that all the rats died during
the experiment their lungs suddenly
collapsed due to pulmonary fibrosis the
kcdc employee then explains that they
didn't die of too much moisture or mold
but due to the inhalation of a poisonous
substance called pH mg this apparently
is a biocidal disinfectant that is used
to clean stuff the surprising thing is
that phmg was found in the room in a
very high concentration as expected Jung
is surprised as he doesn't recall how
that thing ended up there so he rushes
home and starts going through his
drawers in hopes of finding Clues after
a bit of searching he finds a photograph
of a strange chemical called spotless
when he stares at it he goes into a
flashback where it is revealed that
spotless is actually a humidifier
disinfectant his wife saw it on the
adverts and purchased it Jung himself
liked the product as he noticed that it
had been approved by the Korean Ministry
of Health the following day youngju
tries to use her influence to expose O2
the company that manufactures spotless
she writes an article and shows it to
her boss but unfortunately instead of
help she gets scolded he claims that the
move is too risky because if their
assumptions are false they might get
into trouble despite this youngju
doesn't give up and tries doing things
her own way she cause some of her
contacts and asks for help in creating
some bus she also prints thousands of
pamphlets which explain how the evil
company O2 is killing people luckily the
plan works and the News reaches the
media who in turn broadcast it
throughout the country this puts a lot
of pressure on the O2 Executives and
they take their sweet time to come up
with an official statement somewhere
else we are introduced to the Mastermind
behind the evil products and the owner
of o2 Chen he is an arrogant British
businessman who has come to Korea to
sell his products through the way he
talks and treats his employees it is
evident that he doesn't care about
others well-being at all all he cares
about is money and how to grow his
business Empire to handle the situation
Chen summons his assistant SEO wushik
they chat for a while which makes it
clear that the product spotless is
actually harmful however Chen doesn't
care and he asks wushik to resolve the
matter as soon as possible if he
succeeds he will be promoted to the
position of CEO hearing this will she
becomes excited and immediately gets to
work sir our products are killing people
we have to do the right thing how about
some money that sounds really good sir
yeah okay yeah let's do that elsewhere
we see that youngju has quit her job and
moved into a new apartment where she
will conduct her investigation since O2
is constantly denying the murder
allegations the case has been referred
to court youngju herself is an excellent
attorney but she knows that O2 will hire
Big Shots against whom winning would be
impossible hence she visits one of her
former mentors by Young Sook who happens
to be an award-winning lawyer Legend
says that he has fought over 100 cases
and lost none of them youngjoo
enthusiastically asks him for help and
even hands him the case File which has
all the evidence against O2 the young
Sook briefly goes through it and says
I'll think about it unfortunately when
youngjoo reaches her apartment she is
informed that byoungsuk will not join
their cause after all this leaves her
with no choice so she decides to take on
the case by herself the same day as
youngju John and a few colleagues are
discussing many people arrive at the
apartment to show support most of them
are the ones who have been affected by
the Spotless disinfectant Jung is over
the moon that his mission is finally
coming to fruition later youngjoo
gathers all of them and delivers an
emotional speech she explains that their
family has been destroyed by a murderous
company who still aren't willing to take
responsibility for their actions she
also mentions that the case may require
a lot of money but it is not a problem
as Jung is going to sponsor it alone
hearing this all of them start clapping
in excitement and promise to fight
against O2 until their last breaths
ironic choice of words then after months
of planning the big day finally comes it
is the court hearing and a number of
people are present from both parties on
Chen's side he has his assistant wushik
in several world-class attorneys on
young juice side all the affected
families and Jung are present soon the
trial begins and the judge asks youngju
to State her findings however before she
can start Chen's head lawyer arrives he
is revealed to be none other than
youngju's Mentor by Young Sook turns out
that [ __ ] likes money too it turns
out that he backstabbed her and sold her
case File to Chen for a lot of money I
was joking but yeah I was bang on this
makes winning even harder for young Joo
as no matter what she says the
opposition will always have an answer
shortly after when it's Byung tsuk's
turn he confidently states that his
client is innocent to prove this he
requests the judges to conduct the
toxicity test on the disinfectant
spotless the process will take a few
weeks and until then the hearing can be
adjourned youngju who clearly knows that
Chen and his group are trying to buy
some time advises the judges against
approving it but to no avail the trial
is now moved to three weeks later with
the chances of winning the case getting
narrower by the day youngju visits a
popular chemist and asks him to vouch
for them she wants him to explain to the
judges that spotless is a harmful
chemical that can take the lives of
people easily the chemist who turns out
to also be an activist thinks for a
while and then agrees on the other hand
Chen's assistant wushik arranges a
meeting with the government chemist who
is going to carry out the toxicity test
on spotless he bribes him with a large
amount of cash and asks him to alter the
reports that night when Jung goes to the
hospital he sees Wu Chic near his
unconscious son alarmed he screams at
the Intruder to go away but wushik has
come with an agreement he asks Jung to
drop the case and in return his son will
get a pair of new healthy lungs wushik
then leaves but not before handing out
an envelope to Jung a while later Jung
sits by his son and tears up the
envelope he then says sorry son I cannot
accept it surely if John can afford this
trial he can afford to get his kid new
lungs uh I don't know the scene then
cuts to the next trial where youngji's
chemist friend is also in attendance
soon he is called to the front to give
his testimony as everyone listens
anxiously he reveals that spotless
indeed contains phmg which is a very
harmful substance it can cause
congestion coughing or or even lung
failure if not treated on time this
slightly swings the tie in youngju's
favor but just then the defendant's
attorney Byung Sook steps forward with
an article he shows it to the chemist
and makes him read it aloud surprisingly
it is the chemist's OWN article which he
had written in 2004 it states that phmg
is not harmful at all as a result Chen's
group once again gains the upper hand
after a while it is the government
chemist's turn who was previously bribed
as expected he lies that the toxicology
results came out negative meaning
spotless disinfectant is completely safe
as it doesn't contain harmful levels of
phmg he also asserts that his findings
are correct as a member of youngju's
group was with him during the entire
test this shocks the families of the
infected and they begin wondering who
has backstabbed them lo and behold it is
revealed to be none other than Jung
himself with a heavy heart he claims
that the process was fair and there was
no foul play involved as a result of
this Shannon has company O2 win the case
much to the displeasure of young ju the
following day Chen hosts a lavish party
for all of those who helped him among
them is also the chemist who is supposed
to help youngju this reveals that Chen
bribed everyone who came in his way in
the next scene Chen is at the airport
ready to return to London when a bunch
of officers approach him he arrogantly
asks them to move as he has a flight to
catch but the officers inform him that
he is on the no-fly list today this
stuns Chen and he quickly realizes that
he has been found out elsewhere wushik
is watching the news which states that
O2 has finally been exposed the lab
report which the government chemist gave
turned out to be fabricated surprisingly
he starts crying profusely and the movie
goes into a flashback it turns out that
Wu Chic also lost his family due to
pulmonary fibrosis when they inhaled the
poisonous air he knew Chen was
responsible for it but the latter never
accepted it hence wushik made it his
mission to get him behind bars One Way
or Another another flashback reveals
that when Zhang tore the envelope up at
the hospital he noticed a picture of
Byung Sook and his family this
immediately made him realize that
byeung-suk is also a victim so he
contacted him and the two had a formal
meeting they agreed to secretly record
the toxicity test on spotless and then
hand it over to the officials the plan
worked exactly as they wanted and now
Chen is behind bars some days later
Jung's son receives a new set of lungs
and they start living happily thereafter
in the final scene we see several
thousand people protesting outside
Parliament they want to make the
government pay for their negligence in
approving toxic items through the end
credits we get to know that over twenty
thousand people died in Korea and almost
a million suffered from health problems
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching